I started UCLA when I was 16. I go to
Harvard Law I started there when I was
20. by the time I leave Harvard Law I
decided I want to work at a law firm
after about 10 months I turned to my
wife and she turned me and she's like
you're miserable you should just quit
and this is right before we were about
to get married and I was like well we
just got a condo we just got a mortgage
and we're about to get married and she's
like yeah but you're miserable you
should quit at that point I went out on
my own and I was basically making a
living ghost writing so I was editing
truth revolt and then I was doing an
afternoon radio show for three hours a
day so I was working four Jobs Plus
ghost writing plus writing my own books
plus speaking so I was probably making
uh at this point somewhere around 400
000 a year that's fantastic between all
of those jobs